I'm Jill Wiesenthal what you miss today
S&P cut turkeys government debt saying
the coup and it's aftermath risk
undermine turkeys investment environment
growth and capital inflows historically
though failed coup attempts against
democratic governments don't lower
economic growth in those countries after
in the aftermath that is according to
Bloomberg view columnist Tyler Cowen who
now joins us from Washington Tyler thank
you very much for joining us your
inaugural column for Bloomberg view
looked at what coup attempts like we saw
in Turkey mean for subsequent growth
what's the verdict well here I think is
the important point about Turkey their
economy and also their government more
generally was in trouble to begin with
so freedom was being eroded
they were clamping down on institutions
so the coup was a kind of messenger it
brought to the attention of the world
what's going on there but I don't think
the coup itself will have that much
long-run impact you know one thing that
you make a distinction over in the
column is whether it's an autocratic
coup or a democratic coup in the case of
Turkey is Turkey a democracy or an
autocracy because I know technically it
is a democracy but it feels like it's on
its way to being an autocracy that could
be the case what the evidence seems to
show is that when a democracy is
replaced by autocrats then the rate of
economic growth declines if you have a
democratic government and the coup fails
over a 10-year horizon that tends not to
have much impact now this may be
somewhat of an intermediate case but i
think i would stress the point turkey
was already becoming not a democracy you
look for instance at measures of press
freedom turkey was often ranked the
lowest in the entire world and that's
saying something doesn't it also say
something that the coup failed i mean i
read studies that say for countries with
decent gdp growth decent unemployment
and not horrible infant mortality coos
typically failed because the populace
isn't so unhappy that they're gonna
support guys rolling to the streets and
tanks that's correct it's also the case
when you look at history that in
democratic situations often coos come
right after a period of fairly high
growth and that's been the case for
turkey after the financial crisis growth
was over 6% he
quite recently it was over 4% maybe not
a perfect performance but far from bad
and that creates rising expectations but
the point is people are often not quite
willing to jettison something that's
been giving them 4 to 6 percent growth